you
hi everyone it's Jerry on chess calm and
I'm going to try my luck at three
tactics puzzles so let's see playing is
white
oontz probably a study I'm thinking
there's something fancy with attacking
the Queen
yeah most likely a study puzzle in
to check
anything maybe let's consider
is going to go anywhere we give a check
King d7 and I want to keep the night
within reach of the Queen
so suppose we start with this Queen
takes rook we don't have anything good
there how about this check this is maybe
something yes yeah okay so this this is
the idea we give a check here and then
the King has to go to one of these two
and after after check King c7 we can
play rook to a5 and on Queen takes rook
we wouldn't have anything there
what I mean to say on this check King to
e7 then when we go rip to a5 and on
Queen takes rook we would have Knight to
c6 check what suppose check King to c7
Oh
check King c7 we would go tonight to be
five straight away with the fork
okay so after this check the king is
going to go here then we could come over
to a5 and what are the options for the
Queen she doesn't have very many with
the King on e7 she could try to come out
along this diagonal rook on d5 King on
e7 coming over now to a5 and where can
the Queen go she could only go to d6
but when she's on d6 then there's a fork
on f5 so that must be the trick
inserting first to check
then swinging over here and one way or
the other the night is going to land a
fork on the next move so they just went
with capturing the rook and we are now
picking up the Queen
okay let's try number two team white Wow
very simplified
wait to move and draw
okayhow
we draw this
I imagine you have to approach the pond
yeah you have to approach the pond okay
maybe it's probably between one of these
two King after your King deaf for coming
to h3 trying to hang on to this pawn is
an immediate loss pretty much because
King age 3f for the king is flushed away
from defending here and the next king
takes pawn and black still has two pawns
which is win so it's probably going to
be king f4 or f3 why would we maybe go
to f3 maybe so King f3 King takes pawn
King f4
and we're opposite the king
but let's just let's just go direct
let's let's test this variation out
first qingdao forking takes pawn king
takes pawn and if they push then we just
go here
and if the King goes to h3
we'll just approach this pawn and hunt
them down
so King f4 King takes pawn King takes
pawn from that position if they push the
pawn we just go to f4 if they move the
King to the third rank we approach the
pawn and win it next I'm assuming the
test is going to be after king f4 King
g6 what do we do there but that's not
really much of a test King f4 King g6 we
play to e5 and next we're going to scoop
up the f5 pawn I'm not sure what I'm
missing with this one I'm not sure what
the big trick is so oh oh oh here's the
trick um yeah this is what it's going to
test after h5 we have to find an
accurate King move so let's just find
the accurate King move in this position
yeah so this is the last test if we go
here King to f6 and then black is going
to be able to eventually push the pawn
king up for King f6 we have to go back
the King goes to e5 and black continues
to make progress escorting the F pawn
for we have to decide between d5 and d4
going to d6 the pawn just bolts so
what's the trick here if we play to d5
the King goes to f6 and
maybe that's it kingi 5 KF 6 then we
have to go to d4 and what is black going
to do oh excuse me
King d5 King f6 King d4 King e6 is a win
for black
to go to d4 at this moment so that on
king f6 we have the move came to d5
basically we can't allow the King to get
to the e6 square so we have to start out
with King to d4 and now came to d5 and
the pawn takes off but now we can hunt
him down how much further is this going
to go on for should be solved yeah okay
important detail there with the King and
pawn end games
let's try last one team white
okay what is this story here my first
thought is to just maybe sack the Queen
for the nut sack rifice but pick up the
two rooks for the Queen what do we have
anything after that
the most forcing line so let's consider
this first queen takes rook takes Queen
rook takes rook
after a king move to one of these two
what do we have let's say King h7 old we
have there or yeah I don't see you could
follow up there but now I'm seeing maybe
we just capture the night with the
bishop move number one Bishop takes
Knight on takes Queen Bishop takes Queen
takes night and queen takes bishop what
would we do there that would be good
Bishop takes Knight Queen takes bishop
um if we go Queen takes Queen black can
first capture the rook on f1 and only
then recapture on e4 and I don't I'm not
sure what we accomplished with that
sequence what else
what kind of rule this dark square
bishop plays sure we have a check here
but what is that really doing I don't
see if this Bishop covers that and
nearly all other black pieces
so
kind of wandering back to maybe
capturing an FA I just don't see what
the follow-up would be after that though
look on FA King on the seventh rank
double rooks next
make sure I have this right Bishop takes
Knight I'm
the best replies for black to take on a
efore with the queen we have anything
good there wearing a pin so our queen
can't do anything too fancy
I'm not seeing it I don't think it's
takes night
and I'm running
a candidate moves
oh you know what it is it is to just
take the two rooks for the Queen and
then take advantage of this pin
okay so we just take on f8 rook takes
and after the King goes to the seventh
rank we pile up on the pins piece for
some reason I was focused on there only
being one way to move move the f8 rook
and attack the knight but there are two
different points we could go to f e8 or
f4 eat is controlled by the Queen but
rook to f4 will next scoop up the knight
and what's also important to note is
that the knight yes you can move and
give check and there would be discovered
attack against the bishop but our our
Bishop is defended so this must be what
it is we scoop up in this current
position which the material account or
down upon but we're going to be picking
up two rooks
and a night and only investing our queen
thing for black in that position so we
scooped up both rooks ruckus on f8 King
is on the seventh rook to f4 next and I
think we just pick up the night and we
could do that with either the rook or
the Bishop depending on where the King
goes and maybe even taking with the rook
for example after that sequence
capturing on f8 King to g7 rook f4 if
the Queen goes to h5 getting out of the
pin and attacking our Bishop on h4 we
can take the knight with all we could
take with either piece the idea would be
if the king is on g7 we could take we
take the knight and on Queen takes
Bishop we would have rook takes g4 or
the fork of the King and Queen so our
Bishop is indirectly defended or
tactically defended this must be what it
is worked out for being the idea after
we pick up the two rooks for the Queen
and oh that's not a move I considered
okay so now we can't take on e4 with the
rep because the main threat on g2 but we
can take the knight with the bishop and
defend the main threat on g2 that's I
guess the last little test for this one
okay not too bad a group of three in
this session feel free as usual to share
how you did with these in the comment
section below
hope you're having a great day and I
will catch you soon that's all for now
take care
you